yeah what up what up what up [ __ ] boy
drag to the dash on aka hell boy el roy
yo her
yeah i'm on the bootleg cav show right
now you already know we tuned down
live yeah he
yo blackhead podcast special guest man
the dragon is here
what's going on bro welcome man you know
i'm here yes you are um
yo so you just put your uh first album
out in
how many years my last album was helen
max i think that dropped
an so that was my last album
so that's almost 20 years yeah 20 years
because i mean it's close to 20. why why
like what happened what has been going
on with you like why
have has it taken that long to put a
project out man well
oh six no oh seven oh eight i had to get
my releasement from one for birth rider
so i finally got my release but it took
me years
to fight them to really get out of my
contract with that and then um
and then by the time i got out of my
contract in 08 i had my daughter
me going back and forth with lawyers and
stuff like that trying to get out of my
contract made me go broke
yeah i went uh i went broke i was
twisted my big mom's just taking care of
me for the first two three years
and i mean you know uh nothing and uh
then after that uh i mean
it took me a while just to really start
generating some money again
i'm saying so that was like a real
setback because now
i don't use all my money to get out of
my contract but it wasn't like i had
other deals on the table
right now which is on the table now so
let me know with me just dealing with
that and you know but by the same time
um
in oh six i started my company hood
environment that i'm putting out all my
music on now
it just took 10 years for everybody to
catch on because people didn't catch on
to it until like 2015 2016. and then
people started catching on to what i'm
doing and stuff like that but you know
it's just been the grinding world you
find something because i was doing the
real estate
and everything out of pocket yeah i
think it's dope like for you to be so
transparent with that because i feel
like a lot of people
they might see rappers and think well
you know
this guy was on rough riders he had a
deal he had two major
major label releases and and uh
you know sometimes like a lot of times
rather like you're like like
it's it's it's hard to get
really really rich off a rap you know
what i'm saying
like you might get in advance but you're
obviously going to spend that
and then once that's spent it's like you
know so so
i think that's dope because a lot of
people got to understand both sides of
the coin you know what i'm saying like
at the end of the day everyone's bills
need to get paid
that's right every punk bill's got to
get paid everybody uh
his parents now be franchisee
you know and everybody got
responsibilities at the end of the day
you know what i'm saying so you know it
was a real grind for me well in france
because i already had too much bread and
then i was trying my best not to go back
to the street
and stuff like that and then eventually
i eventually had to go back to hustling
on the street you know i'm saying so you
know
i was using that money to bring myself
back into the forefront
it took a couple years because my career
was pretty much
over 105 i would say 0.506 much was done
so you had to go back to to get to
putting your feet in the streets and
getting money that way
damn yo it's crazy because i always
think of your story as like
kind of like a what if like damn like
rough rider is the hottest [ __ ] moving
in
music period right like i went to the
hard knock life tour and i left before
jay-z got on
like i literally was there to see dmx
that was it
i was there i think jay did one song me
and my cousins left i was
13 maybe but we were there for dmx that
was it
you know what i mean but like you were
like the
the perceived heir apparent to the
throne of rough riders
it was like you were on it's dark and
hell is hot
you're on flesh with my flesh you you
were on the you know
the rough riders called those rough
rider compilations were crazy like
uh and it really felt like they were
positioning you to be like
okay we got x is the the flagship but we
but
obviously we got to have some some young
young guns as well
what what do you think went wrong in
regards to
your career and maybe just the whole
entire rough rider situation because it
definitely
there could have been worse situations
for you to be a part of at that time
because at that time that was the
that brand was scorching yeah i mean you
know
what like what i heard it means that i
never really had like
a manager that was like fully behind
me franchise i said like i always shared
with dmx you found chansey dmx was
like a real protector for me so i mean
you know
like his management i had that
management um
his movie agents i had those movie
agents
like i never really had like your own
people
right just drag you know what i'm saying
i never had a movie agent that was like
okay i'm going off and just drag you
fine
say i auditions for those parts because
x put a good word in from me like yo
i'm not going to shoot this example
unless you use dragon
as my brother he looked like me that's
my homie it makes sense the vibe is
there
let's go and that's how i got that right
an excellent one
yeah you know what i'm saying but you
know that's how i got in that movie yeah
and then it led to another movie and
stuff like that you know what i mean but
the reason why that style is because i
mean once something happened with him
as far as hollywood is out yeah they
they
yes right it wasn't like there was
somebody else that could be like okay
also those agents those managers
obviously dmx is gonna be their priority
because at the time he's probably
bringing in so much money
you know what i mean what he said what
he said 30 over probably over 30 million
records just saying by himself
it's crazy i mean look you did have
a lot of people who we see come out of
cruise that you know are big like that
don't get the chance
to put out two albums we see a lot of
like people who are
get signed like think about all the
artists on roughriders that never even
dropped an album
there was a lot like when i came to work
it was
[Music]
i'll go back to like the rough writers
like compilations and i'll see some of
the artists
what's somebody named parlay was there
yeah
uh there was a was there someone named
i know remember young berg when he was a
kid was was uh
i remember when we first met youngberg
and
ex-step young bird on that was we met
him
on what these [ __ ] won from
that video set wow he came through like
a little kid you're working for
but i ain't gonna front he always like
youngberg was always like a boss though
a very talented kid man a little kid
when he came through right
but his entourage he had like six
different
big who is this yeah like he always
moved like a boss even before
he was there but that's one thing that i
could vouch for that dude he always was
a boss as a little kid still is man
doing his thing
shout out to hitmaker man
he always like when i met him he was
like i don't know
11 but boston he walked up on dmx with
six big
security guards like what's up that's
crazy
um at the peak of the rough rider [ __ ]
right
you're on tour you're i mean [ __ ] has
got to be great
but like what like like what point in
time
did you like do you remember vividly
being like oh [ __ ] we're like the
hottest [ __ ] in
in the world because legit like rough
riders for like
that run man there was nothing it was
like all this
puff daddy [ __ ] was happening and then
boom dmx came in ripped all that [ __ ]
away and was like nah
man no more that shiny suit [ __ ] that's
a whole new energy
like what we did we just made it
fair for regular dudes on the street
like just
regular dudes that just happened to be
nice we made it
a big platform for them to be successful
too you don't necessarily got to be uh
flying around in the video and stuff
like that no disrespect to the bad boy
i'm a big fan of that of course but no
but it was like you had that big budgets
to do those kind of videos
yeah you go into where we made it to
where you can actually wear regular
jeans and timberlands and just tell the
homies to come out
yeah yeah 100 um
obviously with ex passing man um i mean
share your thoughts like
like where were you at like you know
obviously you and x had a very close
brother brotherhood and you know i mean
that poster's been there since before he
passed
that's one of my all-time favorites you
know
um and i was [ __ ] that [ __ ] had me
[ __ ] up man
driving through new york city having hot
97 on and they're playing his [ __ ] and
i'm like damn
man like but but where where were you
when you found out about it man
i was in my room his family actually
called me
you know you know like he's actually
blood family what he called me you know
it was like dragging i mean you know we
about to take him off of the uh
life support and stuff like that so i
kind of knew he passed away before a lot
of
people knew you know you know like
before the media uh
knew you know i mean so i was already
hurting down you know
yeah it's rough man because it felt like
uh
we saw that versus with snoop yes it
felt like he was in such a good place
i love to see him i love to see him with
a belly because i was like oh he's
eating good you know what i mean like
like the greatest part about that too
was that
dmx is was always a snoop doggy dog fan
um like when i was watching the verses
and stuff like that that's all i was
thinking about i'm saying because
i know the type of fan he is for snoop
you know what i'm saying like he really
respected like like snoop dogg he
respect that dog right there all right
go [ __ ] that's one person that he always
was a fan of
so that's why when you watch some of the
verses like some of the records that he
put on did you see x get up like oh hold
on this was my
like he really was [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah that was real you know
i was actually like oh snap that's my
joint right was was your relationship
with x
uh did you have one prior to the rough
riders thing or did you like
how did you come into the fold were you
like like with him before the rough
riders or like
like explain your guys's history uh um
well d you know you know d the general
is the one that
put me on the map he was the one that
believed in me first before everybody
and he brought me up to the studio
and and it was like to battle dmx but i
didn't even know it was a battle because
i never was battling at that time right
i found out very fast though you know i
mean as soon as i got in there
boom he was right there they didn't
quite waste any time too i was like i
got there what's up how are you doing yo
drag yo yo turn that beat on my quick
boom and it was straight like that and
then he just started
rapping which was and then i'm listening
to his flow and style delivery
i'm listening to all that i'm like okay
this dude is incredible right here
but at that time i was so hungry
franchisee so i still kept going back at
him back at him back out in the back
and next thing you know a whole hour
went by we was just back and forth
trading bars
and even though i lost that battle like
the whole time
yeah i said he probably battled for an
hour i lost four hours you know what i
mean
but he respected it like you know i mean
you know like to the max like he
he just was like you know what i think
we gonna keep this dude right here i
like this dude he found john saying it
was just something that he always said
that was just in my eyes that reminded
uh uh number you know that i mean
i always just reminded uh
me of him right right yeah yeah i think
like uh
you you guys were it was it's almost
like you guys were so synonymous with
each other
you know what i mean it was like yo you
see dmx you see drag
like the whole batman robin thing let me
know that was set up
us our joint was actually genuine what
year was that because
obviously this was prior to his first
album so when like when was this
that was 1997. 97. album came out in 98.
after that you know i mean you know like
right after we battled it's like me and
him got super cool
so our friends had bought a house in
north carolina and sent us out there
so he worked on his first album and i
worked on my first album you know what
i'm saying
the opposite h2o yeah
at the same time with him in the house
in north carolina while he was working
on this [ __ ] in the room i probably was
in another room in my room upstairs
working on my [ __ ]
do you you know there's so many profound
songs on his first album um
i think that uh damien is one that
always sticks out to me as one of my
favorites
that's one of the songs that he wrote in
north carolina with us in the house
and that's the one that i say you said
that in the world who's actually just
discussing that
that's one of the fastest songs he wrote
he actually timed himself he said you
know what i'm gonna see how fast i could
write you know
yeah i just wrote a song before that
that's kind of fast
but it didn't have the hook he said you
know what i think i could write
even faster than that i mean because i
think i just knocked out a song for like
two and a half hours whole song boom
right so he tried to top that and he
topped it with damian he wrote damien
in an hour and a half wow hook and
everything
that that whole him playing two
different people
yeah not me nah that's x doing that and
he wrote both of those parts and
everything one i win 30 minutes
so you're you were in there while he's
writing this and and uh
yeah no but i'm curious because like
obviously
him rapping from the perspective of the
you know the devil or whatever you want
to call it damien you know yo d what's
up
you a smooth so like was
like did he have the like like talk
about the concept like how did he come
up with that concept because if you guys
were there i mean that's crazy that's
that's one of the crazier records on his
first album that like always just sticks
out to me
yeah yeah like that right there that was
something he was actually dealing with
in life in reality you know i mean that
right there so that was real fam like
that was i'm telling you that's the
fastest record
if because it always felt to me as a kid
not knowing any better
i always thought to myself damn dmx sold
his soul to the devil
and then belly came out and in the
opening scene there's a little boy
and he's quoted [ __ ] from damien and i
was like oh my god he did sell his stuff
this [ __ ] is crazy now mind you i'm a
grown adult now and i'm no better but
like i really thought i was like this
[ __ ] dmx is
he's really like you know what i'm
saying like
so that was something he was like really
battling with just kind of like the
battle
which just just just would like
generally
like he had a hard life yeah
john says so let me you know just as far
as him growing
up as a kid and stuff like that you know
you know he's really from the streets so
you know
sometimes you have to live in the street
and be the homeless
and i've been homeless there's a lot of
artists that actually
came into this game being homeless of
course
you know what i'm saying so that was
some of the demons you know i'm saying
that
that you might be fighting it might be
something like
i'm hungry right now and it's a lady
and and that purse looked real nice and
i'm hungry right now
and i'm contemplating yes even though
you're a good person you might you might
personally but you're like i'm starving
yeah but you might have to make a hard
decision you know i'm saying so these
are decisions that he
had to deal with so he was just not you
know he was just
able to capture it you know i mean you
know and put it in his music
i saw um i watched the uh the rough
riders uh
bt thing uh i figured what what they
call i watched
not the memorial the um documentary the
donkey series they did was it last year
yeah yeah and i didn't realize that uh
it's crazy because
swiss coming up as a young guy in the
camp
you know with some favoritism because of
the family situation but
there was like uh some of the other
producers kind of fell some type of way
about swiss's like ascendants in in
you know obviously swiss is an all-time
great
producer like how was how how was it
being around
swiss early on before he was like a
thing because
he became a thing real quick his sound
became very distinct very fast
and automatically i think everyone just
had swiss beats beats but
early on like you know he was a kid he
was started off as a dj obviously but
like
did you kind of always see that in swiss
like
i was like at the time i was just so
busy working on my album i was
i was just working on opposite h2o i was
trying my best to get beats from anybody
you know what i'm saying really trying
to get some [ __ ] the dmx didn't take he
probably got all the hot [ __ ]
yeah i was i was i was i was actually
trying to
get beats from uh swiss pk greece
right any producer that you know i'm
saying you know
like a lot of my stuff i always work
with a lot of up-and-coming producers so
that's what i just
always was just focused on i was just
focusing on that fire
um the rough rider compilations
were very very uh historic
um and you had some of your
i think some of your dopest moments on
those
uh what was like like when you guys were
making those
compilations where the record like would
you guys like purposely go in and be
like yo
we're working on ride or die volume one
that's what we're working on or was it
like hey look who's got extra records
and everything i put together like how
do those songs come to be
um you know i mean like we are laid like
we are late
some records and stuff like that and
some record to make it there and some
regular to make it there
so that's what it really was like a lot
of people thought
the song would be in juvenile was going
to be on my album
it made it to a compilation it might it
might have should have been on that on
your album yeah because that would have
been the single yeah
a lot of people say that you know what
i'm saying but they wanted that look
for that so it was just like certain
songs
you know like wherever they wanted it to
go you know man
me my job is just writing and just
trying to lay as much songs as possible
what was it like having the locks uh be
brought into the fold um because
at the time obviously the locks were
some of the hottest artists in new york
there was the huge bad boy split and
you know we are the streets is a bible
for a lot of people out here you know
what i'm saying but what was it like
because like yo think about the
competition
within just the crew it's you is x
it's eve it's the lox i mean
[ __ ] young one was fire you know what
i'm saying like
like what was that like having the locks
come into the fold
um i i always seen them in the fold like
i never really seen them out before no
matter where they was at he was always
let me know they always was like locks
are there before me so
oh they were there already yeah i mean i
felt like yeah it was like some yonkers
[ __ ] really it was like some wild [ __ ]
really not there he's not man you know i
mean
like since the first day i got over
there they always was there
x was there you know i mean you know
give me some um
some some of your fondest memories of
being on tour
well first of all we could talk about
the uh there was the rough riders cash
money tour
which was pretty dope but the the tour
that i remember that we talked about was
that heart that hard knock life tour
which was like a moment in hip-hop
method man and red man flying through
the air
[Music]
i actually had to come out twice and
perform
you know i mean you know um on the hard
knock life tour you know what i mean so
it gave me a taste of
being an artist you know i'm saying you
know performing in front of
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
people you know i mean so you know
it kind of made it it kind of molded me
you know i mean
when i started
yeah what because that tour the dynamic
of hove and dmx
at the time was so interesting to me
because obviously
they were both at the top of their game
um
there was all these rumblings about
there being that murdering group
with him and ja rule and hove and
and uh i think anybody who you would
have probably asked at the time probably
would have said the dmx should probably
close that tour out you know what i'm
saying at the time
obviously jay-z is the greatest of all
time but at that time
dmx was scorching
like scorching um was there like any
like how was their relationship because
it we watched the hard knock life
uh documentary like you know
like far dmx and um and whole like i
wasn't there for that so i don't really
know what that was
i know it was always mutual respect no
for sure it was always respectful but
like there had to be some sort of
friendly competition you would think
between
oh yeah probably so yeah like i mean you
know but but
that's just new york yeah always who's
the king of new york talk
yeah that's that's that's that's what
that's about that's that
that's the new york thing that you know
i mean you know we're always
in competition with each other you know
you know that's just new york
yeah i feel like new york is probably
the most competitive city in hip-hop
especially back then because everybody
was who's the king of new york i think
he's gone so who's the king of new york
it was like is it hov is it ghost based
killer is it dmx is it
is it fat joe is that's crazy um
so obviously you know what ex passing
the way he did man you know he's had a
troubled uh history when it comes to i
mean also a very open history when it
comes to
his his you know use of certain
substances and stuff like that was that
something that was like was that
something that
everyone around him kind of knew was
going on or was it something that
became worse over time like yeah with
the drugs
x never did any drugs around me ever not
one time
i put that on my daughter he knew not to
do that around me so
i don't really know too much about the
drugs like like like far as the drugs
i put this on my daughter my grandma my
mom's everything like he never
ever did drugs around me not one but did
you guys know that that was a thing
or was it like if you didn't see it so
you didn't really know or
i never really uh i mean you know he was
such a dope artist and i was just
so focused on that part of his life you
know i mean you know
especially with him not trying it around
me having that respect for me
i just always looked at him as the great
artist that he is that's it i never
looked at him
in no other way but that you know what
i'm saying at what um
what what year did you end up kind of
starting to split away from
rough riders and being around x so much
because yeah i think you said
helen back him out in o203
so at that point in time i'm trying to
think oh 304
that's probably around the time the
grand champ is that grand champ type
era yeah like three when we were
shooting crazy
he was working on his third album so he
was working on uh
and then there was x because that was
his third album yeah
um hey because you said you were at the
what these [ __ ] want video so that
was on that album
did did your relationship with
roughrider souring affect your
like your relationship with x uh nah
um me and x was always brothers always
remain brothers
you know what i'm saying so you know we
always look genuine that's like when we
came across each other they were
straight brother [ __ ] there wasn't none
of that
let me like like the relationship that
me and x had it wasn't just
it wasn't just based on music you know i
mean you know it was it was like some
real genuine [ __ ]
that's yeah when's the last time you
spoke with them last time i scoped the x
probably me
i don't know maybe like
seven eight months ago you stopped for
85 times and i mean
like like it was months before he uh
passed and i mean because he was working
on his album
right and i was working on
and i just did a big transition moving
from the east to the west
so it was kind of hard for me when i
first got to the west because i didn't
really know
how the west really moved like that it's
my first
so time was so focused on his joint i
was just focused on my job but we spoke
yo have to stop the bootleg head podcast
real quick and shout out our sponsor odd
socks
that's right they've been holding us
down from the jump man and they're
not only the makers of the most
comfortable socks in the world shout out
to odd socks
but they also now got the drawls man the
boxer briefs are so
fire they're so soft they feel great on
your ass
your nuts whatever you're into you know
what i'm saying whatever you got they'll
cover them up real real comfortably
and ladies you know you could wear these
things to sleep so go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg kev save 20 off
you know
one of the licenses they just got that i
love are the naruto socks
they just got the naruto socks of course
they got wwe those are mankind socks
ladies and gentlemen
spongebob and shout out to the the goat
ric flair so what you got to do get you
some odd socks
thank me later save 20 off at checkout
by using the keyword bootleg kev
at oddssoxoficial.com and we are
super proud that they're presenting this
podcast let's get back to it
yeah i think that there's obviously an
unfair expectation
um when we see someone like x pass away
and how he passed away
where you know there's so many what it
could have should haves that people
try to bring up like hey well you know
you know maybe people closer to him
could have spoke up or
or or intervened or you know
uh had an intervention or whatever the
case is but
you know i think that um
i think that there was probably a lot of
that that we didn't see
because i know i know you know obviously
swiss is is uh
you know somebody who was very close to
x but did did you feel
like maybe looking back that there were
people around him that
could have maybe done more way back then
at the time x is the hottest rapper in
the world there's boatloads of money
coming in
so i'm sure that like some stuff was
ignored because it's like hey whatever
makes them happy we're just gonna do
because the money's coming was there
something that you think
like like you like like thinking back
was there more that you think
other people could have did not not
necessarily saying yourself of course
i just always looked at ex as an artist
i never looked at them
how everyone else views or or
or how someone else viewed that
situation i just looked at him as one of
the greatest rappers i've ever heard in
my life
i mean he's obviously your brother your
friend right
yeah i mean i think it's a it's it's
just it's just tragic man anytime
someone passes from that
like it's like [ __ ] man like that
everyone starts to think like well
what a coulda like my mom's like my
mom's
was a crackhead my pops was a crackhead
uh
my uncle did drugs and stuff like that i
had
i had so many you know you don't like i
mean you know
when you from the hood and stuff like
that and you grew up around that like
that's
just all you know you pretty much numb
to it
you know what i'm saying so you know
when it came down to the relationship
with me and dmx
i just looked at him as one of the
greatest artists i've ever seen in my
life
that's it i i didn't really navigate for
a chance like let me
i didn't i didn't really get into uh now
you know
like me and him always had a respect for
each other where
i mean we didn't i mean we had respect
[Music]
like x was an older brother to me you
know i mean you know he wasn't like
like somebody i could be like actually
what the [ __ ] you from trying to say
like
i was his little brother right right i
just looked up to him
like how you would look up to your big
brother but you might not be knowing
that he's out there
robbing liquor stores or whatever he
finds out or you know he's your big
brother right
right yeah that's real [ __ ] um that's
fair man
you talk about the uh the cash money
tour which was a dope moment in hip
hop to have both of those crews on the
road at the same time
um obviously uh
i i miss those kind of tours i feel like
we don't get those kind of tours in
hip-hop anymore
like that kind of energy where there was
that big artist all together at the same
time on the same bill i feel like
there's too much ego on hip-hop now
where that kind of [ __ ] don't even fly
no more
yeah it's it's just way too much ego um
i mean you know
um the word platform
it's used way too much oh no you know i
don't know if i already want that on my
platform
yeah it's some [ __ ] everyone's so
worried that yeah
like i hate that word now like think
about it rough riders and cash money
two different genres like not two
different
pieces of the country two different
totally different sonically movements
coming together on the road is [ __ ]
crazy that wouldn't even happen these
days
it'd be like if [ __ ] you know imagine
if like
kendrick lamar went on tour with [ __ ]
nba young boy people be like
what that don't even make sense give me
some like what
what's like your some of your favorite
stories about that tour like give me a
story from that tour that you kind of
look back on that was pretty crazy
um just me being able to actually come
out every night and rock the crowd
that's the biggest story for me if i'm
trying to say just me actually going out
there and representing drag
you know man you know that's the biggest
story for me that's that's what i'm
going to always remember you know
man you know did you and juvenile
perform together the record off the uh
the last show in new york that's it the
hotel we didn't perform in that one time
but you guys did it do it once
did you um do that song together in the
studio because nowadays we think we
didn't do this
so it wasn't together
[Applause]
[Music]
wow that [ __ ] that's that's wow um
you just put a new album out which is by
the way you're spitting man
it feels like like it feels like you had
like you you've almost like you got a
a bro [ __ ] point to prove it's been
almost 20 years since the last one it's
like you can't come with no [ __ ]
like this album right here it started
from bof part one
and i had dropped that a couple years
ago and it did
real good on the streets you know what
i'm saying you know the videos
let me know but like some of the videos
on there i got two three million views
on my fan page so
it did real good shout out to dj get it
right um
i mean he's the one that actually
started that
because i didn't even want to drop no
mixtape right my buddy
but he was like nice it's doing good
dragging
trying to say like you might could do it
and i mean i had just dropped the
choking freestyle
that did like three four million on the
streets so
uh i mean you know um so after that
it made me link up with them and do part
two so we did part two and then we did
part three together
part four was kind of catering to those
fan base that loved
that uh saga but i really wanted them to
know that i know how to do music too so
i put a lot of different music and
you know after the fourth or fifth song
if you notice
the album go like another direction
which is i mean
into a baby type right zone you know
what i'm saying
because you know part one two and three
i really was just like i'm back i'm
spitting bars did you talk about anybody
but
part four i didn't really care about
that i really just wanted people to
enjoy the project
who's um because there's so many
incredible emcees that are
thriving right now in hip-hop um who are
some of the artists that
you're fans of that are currently kind
of like on the newer side of things
um
i like i like rowdy rich
alrighty of course of course man
i like money bag yo money bag yo it's
fire
you know i'm a big fan of kendrick big
fan of j
cole you [ __ ] with any of the griselda
guys at all
yeah yeah that grizzle [ __ ] is like
that's the energy like i feel like has
been missing man
it's like that that's the energy that
new york was once on of course
i have much respect for um
foreign
yeah and i'm a huge fan of them
i mean because they are just just
keeping it hip-hop they
they're leaders and they know that and
they're not following
john said they actually
[Music]
uh so you were in exit wounds cradle to
the grave
what are the movies were those the two
uh
i've been exiled crazy grave i shot
another movie
with me lover and dr dre shout out to
those guys are legends
cradle to the i mean excellent said
steven seagal
cradle to the grave had jet li at the
time i mean obviously those are two of
the greatest like uh
martial artists of all time when it
comes to just on movies
especially jet li man and that was like
early on in jet li is like you know
there was i feel like jackie chan was
like the first guy in the 90s
that like like was a superstar in china
and crossed over and it worked in
america and then there was jet li
what was it like being on set with jet
li like you know what i'm saying like
cool dude you know what i'm saying you
know he's real short you know what i
mean
and um he barely spoke english but he
tried his best to speak to me in english
you know i'm saying so
i kind of respected that you're not man
because he let me know his english was
real bad i know
it might look like he can talk a little
bit but no yeah you could yeah
it's real like he had to have a
translator
yeah there's the whole time on every
single part
did did you like um you know
acting wise i feel like x's potential as
an actor wasn't even
sniffed like i feel like it could have
been so much bigger like
for some reason i mean i don't know we
just stopped getting dmx movies you know
we had a
there was so many fire ass dmx movies i
don't know if it was whatever was going
on in his personal life and he ended up
stop
acting as much but um what did you like
did he did he try to like kind of
give you a lot of pointers on the acting
[ __ ] early on
because he was a solid actor yeah unlike
nas
nas was a terrible actor in that movie
i'm just shout out to nas
but xxx is the reason why i'm in movies
of course that's the reason for dragons
anything you've seen
that i did is probably because he did it
first and allowed me to do it after
you know what was it like um described
steven seagal's a very uh interesting
fellow what was what was being on a
movie set with steven seagal like
it was real interesting because he took
a liking to me you know what i'm saying
for real you know i mean you know out of
everybody when they said he didn't
really rock with too many people
like stephen cigar the type of person
that if you rock with your rock with you
if you don't he don't like like you know
i mean so
you know with him actually taking a
liking to me
is like weird because i grew up on him
you know i'm saying
you know i was a huge fan and all that i
was actually able to tell him
some of my favorite movies that he did
wow like i'm saying that he was telling
me what was going on at that time so i'm
just sitting there listening
so you know it was dope right now like
stephen cigar was actually
a cool dude super cool dude super cool
dude with me that's serious you know
what i'm saying so
yeah you know he used to be in the
studio with casey and joe joe so
you know he's into the music that's so
rare can you imagine walking into a
session and it's
and it's casey and jojo and steven
seagal
all the yeah were you ever in the studio
with them at the same time oh i was
about to say
that have been fun that's gotta be crazy
he's gonna tell me stories and all that
stuff
he's into the music the whole you know
you know he's aware
yeah damn that's that's wild man um
the other thing i think that is dope is
like you know you for people who are
watching this who might have the same
situation like you have a speech
impediment and
you have never let that be an excuse for
you to do what you want to do right
and you're also um you know
some people are shamed by that or they
do their best to hide it but i think
that it's important for
there's somebody who could be watching
this right now who's going through the
same situation
and might want to be a rapper or might
want to think you might want to
do tv or whatever and might not think
that they can you know what i'm saying
like
and that's why you know like when i
first let it out
and i mean you don't on the suede show
you know you know that i have a
stuttering problem i actually went up
there not trying to hide it
and stuff like that right now i've been
studying a little bit
yeah they're pretty much gonna see it
but i've been working on it
you know i mean so i'm not as bad but
my stuttering is real bad you know what
i'm saying so
i just stopped hiding it because i
wanted people to know
all right i mean you know this is my
imperfection perfection
you know i'm not perfect i want them uh
i mean you know because i know it's a
lot of people that's that's probably
are capable of doing so many things and
they'd be nervous on how somebody's
gonna look at it
yeah that'd be the whole thing of when
you stutter and you catch a real bad
stuttering and then you wondering
if they're looking at you like you're
crazy right right right
yeah with me being in the position that
i am this is
this is what let them know that no
you have a stuttering problem but you're
not [ __ ] you're trying to say you're
not
slow i'm very intelligent well you've
also got had
an extremely successful you know career
using your voice and and and i think
that that's
got to be inspirational because that
would be the single most insecure thing
that anybody could probably do
and that's decided to be an artist a
musician you know a sing a rapper
i really stopped doing interviews
because of my stuttering and then i said
nah you know what that's not
a way where i could really show them
that it can actually be done
with a stuttering problem i mean you
know i was born with this i got on both
sides of my family
you know my father's stutter when my
father said i saw my father yeah
my mom's huh my grandfather's stuff
badly he found childhood was he just
um which he just passed away but uh
he had a real bastard of a problem to
the point where you came and called him
on the phone
you know what i'm saying so you know i
actually got it on both sides of my
family you know i mean so
i just be wanting people to understand
and know
that it can still be done even even with
it you found
something right now i can barely speak
listen i'm gonna tell you this man i
press play on your new project and i'm
like i haven't heard a dragon project
and
since i was i was in high school maybe
even junior high
was riding around to yesterday and i was
like yo
it might like i know not even gassing
you man like this might be the
lyrically the most tip top i've i've
heard you
he was really getting getting off bro
because you know sometimes even you
press play like let me hear this [ __ ]
you know i'm afraid i'm
almost like i'm afraid it's just gonna
sound dated or something or it's gonna
be
i hit play on that [ __ ] i said this
intro is great
then the next one and i was like damn
and you had some lines in there i was
like oh god
man yeah man i think dude i think like i
just had this conversation with jay
mills
uh not too long ago and i think that
there is a
a rare opportunity um for artists such
as yourself
who are lyrically inclined to really uh
just you know thrive
because i think the pandemic has made
people listen to music differently
we're not staying like most of the
country isn't standing on couches this
the last year
in the nightclub popping bottles they're
in their cars
or they're at home listening in their
headphones so the substance and the
lyrics
that's why if you see the grammy
nominations from 2020 it was all
real rap [ __ ] it was voice the five nine
it was freddy gibbs it was
it was all all lyrical ill rap [ __ ]
and i think that you know another thing
too is like
don't hold on to music anymore you know
i think if anything if anything uh that
griselda and westside gunn and conway
and benny the butcher have taught us
over the last
you know four years is run that indy
catalog
up
me i got dropped i mean you know like i
started my own record label code
environment and we put out music every
week or every two weeks and and that's
not just songs what i'm saying but we
don't really rely on dj's
so we put the song out with the video
every day
smart so when you first hear the record
you're looking at it
that's fire yeah that's smart man um
were you able to make it to
x's memorial service yes how how was it
because i mean i thought it looked so
amazing on tv
uh i mean i know kanye helped design
like the the stage and
it just looked great man it really you
know it was obviously a very sad day but
like
um how was it for you to go to that
it was a lot for me to go to that you
know i mean you know
like i was in denial for a long time so
i like
like me i had a hard time accepting it
like you know i'm saying you know
i'm going to make my homie the rest
like i had a hard time accepting it so i
actually booked my flight the day off
like
i was really contemplating it you know
i'm saying but i mean you know
overall i'm just glad i went for dmx
yeah i mean it also you know just has to
bring up so much old feelings and then
obviously every i mean everyone
through probably through your hip hop
career was there
you know i mean um were were you able to
reconcile or see anybody there that you
hadn't talked to for a while
or i was just there for dmx that was it
in and out
i was there for dmx dmx uh passed away
so i was acting in such of that matter
you know
i saw you know obviously swiss's speech
um i thought was really
i thought i mean what he said could be
applied to anybody in your life
right like as far as just like being
there for people not just when they're
gone like being there for when they're
here
um what what did you think of uh of
just the services like like swiss's
speech i thought was
anybody should watch that if they
haven't seen it you know he kept it a
thousand
um but what were your thoughts on what
he had to say and
my thoughts was on my speech but you're
worried about your own [ __ ]
my speech um was really focused
on what he had done for me you know i'm
saying that what he is
to me and i'm hurting that passed away
how how hard of that is is that to write
like to put that together
into words um see my speech just came
from the heart
i didn't write it so you just went up
there and just just told your truth man
just spoke exactly what it was you know
man so
let me know let me know like like with
my speech
being straight from the heart real
genuine
it made me uh shed a tear too you know
i'm saying because i know where
uh let me you know um where it came from
right a real place me i i just i
i just was uh i'm you know happy that
everybody
showed dmx love um
you know the love that he deserved you
know what i'm saying you know that was
my thing my thing was just
showing up for the homie that's it um
have you been privy to hear uh his new
album at all anything from his new album
um i i heard two records from it dope
you know man you know um i mean you know
like dmx never really put out too much
um songs that wasn't great he was just
great period
this is true i wish we would have got
more man
yeah i always think back like what if
dmx just never let up on this rap [ __ ]
a lot of people's careers would have
been and because man i feel like he let
up
and that's when you had the job rule
slide in and have this like you know the
r
b wave and it was really only because x
kind of just let up on this [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying and went into
acting and
you know what i mean it was like it kind
of left a whole yeah it it's crazy
would there ever be a or would you ever
consider
being a part of a rough rider reunion i
mean obviously without x
that's going to be hard to accomplish
but focus on my record label called hood
environment
which we just dropped the album march
5th and we're doing
successful with that company that's a
company i started since 06.
it's 2000 it's 2021 so this
has been a long grind um i got
my release from rough riders in 07.
i was uh uh i mean you know
and um i started my record label from
then so
i just been so focused on that i mean
you said that that lawsuit kind of
broke you right so i can only imagine
that getting on the other side of that
like the animosity
you might have towards rough riders in
general like
who told you that no i'm saying that you
you said that after you got
released that going through and hiring
lawyers and stuff you ended up like
kind of broke and i ended up being
broke i ended up being uh homeless he
had to go back to the streets
but i had to go back to the streets and
restart my career
so you ended up homeless after rough
riders yeah yeah
i was i i was actually homeless while i
was still on rare fighters
you were homeless so so explain to me
being homeless like wouldn't you say
homeless what does that mean i have a
place to stay
so you actually were definitively
homeless while still being on rough
riders
so i started my company and just kept
building for the past 10 years
so did d and y know you were homeless or
was that something where it was like it
was the
the relationship was so sour i don't
know
like once i left rough riders i focused
on hood environment right
damn for people watching this man
that that's that's a low that is hard to
come out of being homeless right
especially being drag on from rough
riders
hitting homelessness having to get back
to the streets to get your money up
the perseverance that that takes the
dedication the like mental fortitude
that that takes to not let that [ __ ]
break you got to be crazy man
yeah yeah i mean you know
at the end of the day i don't really
like rely too much
on the people that's down here on this
earth with me if i'm trying to say i
rely on god
god got me you know i mean so you know
i'm here on the strength
of god i am living proof that
god will help you if you ask him you
know i'm saying if you pray if you
prayed up
if you keep yourself within the bubble
of prayer
then god will be there for you you found
john say and and
and and even for the people that don't
pray but just believe in god
your father said god got them too you
know what i'm saying so my thing was
just
let me like once i did that i just focus
on my company and then the streets
started catching on to it
so i just stayed focused on that how
long was that period of time that you
were actually homeless like before you
got to play like how long
like how long was that maybe like a year
and a half two years or something like
that
wow damn man well look you came a long
way bro
yeah and uh as listen you're a part of
history yes sir you are a part of
history man
and how did you think the um the the
documentary came out on bt
the the was it was it was it uh the
fight was it five episodes
something like that oh you didn't watch
it i didn't watch it i didn't watch it
i thought i thought it was dope i mean
again i'm i'm a [ __ ]
when i was a kid i used to tag up dmx
and roughrider logo on all my folders
and that was all the posters i had in my
room and
so i was just like yeah this [ __ ] is
great but yeah it's
it's also kind of got to be crazy too
because like
you're kind of like a part of a
fraternity that'll forever exist on this
planet that has nothing to do with
hip-hop
like the motorcycle club [ __ ] is so big
just the culture of that r
that has nothing to do with the music or
the record label it's just so big
it's like you know what i'm saying well
look your album is out
yes um i hope you keep putting out
you're gonna keep putting out more
albums
yes i'm already working on another
project that's
so dope right now is it's out of here
you know i mean so you know um
we don't have a name somebody just used
the damn name
but they didn't know which name was it
supposed to be
it was a name that just been used right
so you know
but they didn't know that that was the
name of my city right right right so you
gotta switch the name up now
switch the name up now choosing the name
but it's all good though and i mean you
know the music is great it sounds
super big you know i mean you know it's
it's
it's it and it's and it's actually
better than bof4 you know what i mean
because it got just a little bit more
of a music type of vibe on this joint
that i just know everybody gonna love
hey what i didn't ask you about uh i was
curious about eve man
eve was uh i think when we when we
always talk about the greatest female
hip-hop rappers of all time for some
reason i feel like people kind of just
don't bring her up and i think that's
just because she hasn't been active for
a while
but like uh what was your relationship
like with eve
brothers and sisters so just like any
brother or sister relationship highs and
lows and it was always love
i said it's always glad i said brothers
and sisters you know i mean you know
you can actually go to my instagram page
actually i think like my last post or
the post before that you see
when we sell each other is genuine you
know i mean you know it's brothers and
sisters that's it
that's a beautiful thing man well look
dragon the legend
go get the album yes sir go stream it
cav and uh man welcome to uh cali too
yes yes yes glad to have you on the west
coast i love the weed man
boom z ready